[Aplausos]
pueden ser blancas grises marrones de
madera de hierro con rejas o con vidrios
hasta he llegado a ver cortinas en su
lugar
todas distintas y con una única función
separar mundos lograr privacidad
[Música]
cuando el tío cerraba la puerta yo
empezaba a estremecer me y temblar
pero a él no le importaba
[Música]
no tenga miedo vas a ver qué lindo es
yo les quiero mucho por eso esté con
ustedes
si el tío lo dice debe ser verdad
sentía dentro de mí no solo su carne
sino que pensaba que me dejaría algo
malo
a su olor lo recuerdo siempre a todos
los olores de los miles que hicieron lo
mismo años después
si es así
el olor nunca se va
queda la piel en las sábanas en el aire
creo que el dolor tampoco se va o bien
el dolor que siento deambula mi piel y a
mi adentro
siempre me dijo que me quería
que vence eso para cuidarme y demostrar
su amor
si lo decían seguro la verdad aunque me
doliera yo confiaban en
aunque el pudor me llegaba yo confiaba
en él
[Música]
porque siempre me cuidaba con esa manera
de cuidar que sólo el kilo sabe
fue así que aprendí lo que era el amor
su forma de amar
dentro de mi cuerpo me ardía me
desgarraba me irritaba
pero eso era el amor
así que decir
muchas veces soñé que se moría
el tiempo transcurre de modo diferente
poco para ellos interminables para mí
el peso sobre mi cuerpo aplasta cada vez
un poco más
voy afinando me hasta volverme
transparente
la desnudez ya no me avergüenza el pudor
ya no me molesta pero el recuerdo sigue
siendo insoportable
[Música]
hoy yo no le creo el tio disfrute de su
partida jamás lo llore el me mintió y
así no se trata a una niña
porque me entrego tantas veces si él
tenía que cuidarme adentro estuve yo y
tanto más
perdón
el abuso sexual infantil es algo de lo
que debemos hablar y contarles que estoy
aquí porque forme parte de ese
porcentaje que es los niños abusados el
47% de 6 a 12 años hemos sido violados
por un familiar directo y en la otra
lámina podemos ver que el 75% no lo
vuelve a decir
hablar del abuso sexual infantil
no sólo implica que hay niños abusados
como está ocurriendo hoy en los clubes
sino también en que nos transforman en
algo que no servimos más o que
ya no somos importantes según entender
entendí yo como muchos otros niños que
habrán pasado por lo mismo el abuso
sexual infantil es algo de lo que a
veces inconscientemente o consciente
somos cómplices o cuando no denunciamos
nos transformamos en cómplices de esto
es sumamente importante creerle a los
chicos siempre aconsejo o digo que no
guardemos secretos para mí la palabra
secreto era muy muy terrible muy triste
porque tenía que ver con que yo no podía
hablar de lo que él me hacía
después de ahí me transformé como en una
prostituta preparada si se quiere para
el momento una prostitución no elegida
una prostitución de la cual nunca
hablamos pareciera que ocurriese en todo
en cualquier otro ámbito menos en el
nuestro así que bueno estuve en el mundo
de la prostitución muchos años yo
siempre dio con el efecto que me trajo y
la violación que tuve de niña
entonces bueno tenemos que entender que
la prestación a la podemos elegir nunca
como trabajo
y tuve que pensar me
para pensar me pasaron dos cosas
sumamente una extremadamente violenta y
muy triste y la otra mucho más alegre y
les quería contar yo paraba en
constitución después de muchos días de
estar prostituida sin elegir y hubo una
pelea que siempre sabemos cómo empieza
una pelea pero no cómo termina y
degollaron a una compañera al lado mío
con un pico de botella
y la verdad es que
creo que inmediatamente me pregunte y si
hubiera sido yo
[Música]
y va a devolverle a mis hijos lo que
pasó conmigo y con mi madre que murió
cuando yo era niña entonces dije no esto
no lo voy a querer para mis hijos
creo que empecé a pensar me sin saber
que me pensaba
y volviéndome a santa fe a mi ciudad
natal
[Música]
lo primero que me dice mi hija cuando
llego a mi casa es que estaba embarazada
y en mayo y tiene 12 años así que ahí me
volvía a pensar y me volvía a preguntar
qué era lo que quería para mi futuro y
bueno no quería estar en una esquina por
supuesto no quería ya con mis hijos
habíamos vivido todo todo el mundo
violento para mis nietos no quería lo
mismo así que bueno ahí hice como un
cambio diferente y me transformé como en
otra como nuestra elena que escribió un
libro donde donde la idea es seguir
pensando que se puede transformar y
cambiar no me consideré nunca una
víctima quizás al comienzo en mi niñez
cuando uno no sabe de qué se trata sí
en todo caso soy una sobreviviente de
tanto dolor de tanta angustia de tantas
tantas violaciones sistemáticas que
atraviesa la prostitución siempre digo
que son violaciones sistemáticas porque
no estás de acuerdo con lo que está
pasando sino que alguien paga y te
transforma en un objeto entonces haces y
obedeces a tu amo en este caso
y un poco para también contar que
pareciera que las cosas violentas o
estos de una menos o que no están
matando todo el tiempo
a las mujeres pareciera que pasara en
otro país en otro lugar y no nos pasará
a nosotros aquí en santa fe el sunchales
la reconquista en rosario
nosotros yo después de 9 devolver a mi
ciudad natal arme una ong que se llama
mujeres en actividad invito a que vean
la página del trabajo que hacemos
nosotros le llamamos trabajo de campo y
lo que hacemos es llevarle preservativos
a las compañeras decirles dónde pueden
hacer una denuncia si la necesita si
necesitan su documento de los niños
tratamos de empoderar las la única
herramienta que hay no hay políticas
públicas ni a nivel nacional ni
provincial ni nada que se le parezca así
que quería contarle esta anécdota muy
triste que viví y ya está ensayando esta
charla que iba a dar hoy también
contarles que en la ruta 34 cada vez que
vengo con el colectivo veo a compañeras
para los arbolitos
que también padecen violaciones
sistemáticas por supuesto
el 20 de febrero de este año en una de
mis recorridas me encuentro con una de
las compañeras le doy preservativos que
le damos en una bolsita y entonces le
digo perdón que se cruza otra niña
inmediatamente y me pide preservativos
le doy y le digo a la compañera que está
en la esquina es menor y me dice no no
es menor si le digo es menor no tiene
dos hijos
bueno no la habilita a ser mayor
le vuelvo a repetir es menor me dices
bueno si tiene dos hijos tiene quince
años
entonces cómo se aprendí en esta
militancia que estoy teniendo un montón
de cosas le digo mira que ahora strata
que puedes ir presa que es otra cosa que
hay una ley entonces ella
automáticamente me se te voy a contarlo
con el paso del otro día
bueno entonces me cuenta que una niña de
14 años porque ella presta a su casa
para que el hotel salga para que no
pague en el hotel los mal llamados
clientes
y
entonces se ocupó el señor con la niña y
la niña empezó a los gritos y su marido
según ella sufrió lo empezó a la niña
empezó a editar y el cielo entró a ver
que para pegarle al cliente y a ver qué
había pasado y la niña dijo no le hagas
nada porque no me está pasando
absolutamente nada y entonces porque
editas
porque estoy abordando ayer me puse
perejil y estoy aportando
perdón entonces en esto con esta
anécdota la quería contar porque abracé
a mi compañera que no la conozco tanto
pero para mí son somos todas iguales por
el lugar en que ocupamos la resaca de la
sociedad
le dije que que había hecho me dijo la
saqué a patadas el cielo la estaba
esperando la esquina en el auto se la
llevó digo qué pena que no pudiste hacer
otra cosa llevarla a un hospital a
acompañarla algún lugar porque la verdad
es que hoy no sabemos qué pasó con esa
niña de 14 años hoy además que se está
hablando mucho del aborto y de tantas
cosas más
bueno y ahora me gustaría que se varones
no puedo ver mucho desde aquí pero que
me levanten las manos y varones
en pocos varones hay varios varones
bueno
decirles que nosotras las mujeres me
gustaría hablarles de hoy día en este
momento directamente a los varones
nosotras las mujeres
tenemos 32 encuentros nacionales de
mujeres donde hacemos talleres
maravillosos nos juntamos como mujeres
nos empoderamos queremos la igualdad por
lo menos desde mi objetivo es este no es
que queremos que sean menos sino que
seamos lo más equitativo posible y
y en esto y más imaginarse los varones
no estoy diciendo que lo están aquí
consumen lo que digo que otros varones
que consumen prostitución
deberían hacer una revisión con sus
amigos o con sus conocidos
de cómo deberíamos dejar de consumir y
de violentar a los cuerpos de mujeres
porque en realidad parece muy está todo
muy bien con que vayamos de [ __ ] cuando
sé que hay un casamiento o que digamos
que está bueno vamos a pescar y llevamos
a una niña como pasa en reconquista en
que yo trabajo mucho así entonces
decirles si se imaginan a sus hijas su
nieta sus sobrinas sus hermanas su prima
su madre su abuela porque hay mujeres de
70 años también en las espinas digo se
la imaginan ustedes prostituídas
y se imaginar a un señor de 60 años
subiendo una niña de 12 años su auto
imagínense el dolor que a mí me causa
con todo lo que he vivido y con todo lo
que sigo viendo en las calles
aquí el 3 por ciento de los varones
presentes podrían ser presuntos
violadores
pensemos en eso pensemos en que los que
me consumieron mi cuerpo 18 años en una
esquina eran papas eran hermanos eran
tíos eran abuelos eran primos eran
vecinos eran amigos
así que es sumamente importante que
revisemos también cómo educamos a
nuestros niños en nuestros nietos
yo no quiero a mis nietas de mis viñetas
en ninguna esquina no quiero ninguna
niña en las esquinas
ah
[Aplausos]